the bootle C show Power 98.3 here with
one of the biggest superstars in the WWE
we got the World Heavyweight Champion
right here in the building we got
Alberto Del Rio how you doing man very
good man thank you thank you for having
us hey yeah great great uh match I was
just telling you man you had a good
match at SummerSlam with Christian who I
think is one of the most underrated
Superstars we had fantastic I I every
time I work with Christian it's just we
have fun it's it's you know one of my
favorite performers one of my favorite
wrestlers of all time um how excited are
you about this uh potential uh situation
with RVD that is brewing uh with uh of
course your ex ring announcer Roberto
Rodriguez well I don't care about
Ricardo he can doic yeah he can do
whatever he wants he was uh taking money
out of me for years and years and now
he's gone I fir him and uh RBD can have
him and you know about RBD I'm pretty
sure it's going to be uh a a great
series of match
right the WWE universe is going to be
happy because we have good chemistry
he's an amazing performer I'm an amazing
performer he just going to be good um do
you feel when you what exactly happened
um was it just kind of like a
development of of your character as far
as getting rid of Ricardo Rodriguez or
was that something that that you had a
lot to do with or did upper management
have a lot to do with that how' that
come to be no that was a company uh uh
Ricardo and I our friends our friends
outside the business I want the best for
him he's a great guy he's a he has a lot
of
talent and and I'm pretty sure he's
going to be just fine I don't know where
he's going right now to be honest I know
he's going to be with RBD but I don't
know what the situation is going to be
after that but I'm just wishing the best
for Ricardo because he's a great guy
indeed um last week on Raw I noticed you
had some black eyes and I know that you
know you're a real fighter you do MMA
you know you've done the pride stuff did
you get into it like something something
real after SummerSlam or what happened
with the the black guys no you know we
do shows we do over 200 uh shows per
year and we had a live event in Portland
and you know it's
just yeah yeah things happens when when
you're in wrestling you know it was it
was just an accident but you know how it
is they always like to talk and they
always like to make stories of their you
know it's just it's just part of the
business it's part of the game yeah you
get hurt um you've had I mean you've
been a world champion for the
predominant part of the last year or so
um what are some of your favorite feuds
that you've had in the last year cuz I
feel like you've had some good ones uh
well R my sterio was the first one and
he was fantastic H Christian of course
like you said he's he's the most
underrated wrestler in WWE because he is
amazing uh John Cena of course I had a
lot of fun when I was working with Cena
I had the chance to go to Mexico as WWE
Champion and and we had TV in Mexico
City in fact and it was Cena against
Alberto Rio in front of my people in
front of my family it was it was great I
feel like um my favorite uh moments that
you've had would be definitely uh when
you went against uh you had your your
Runnings with um Jack Swagger and and Z
cter the the promos that you and and
Ricardo would cut were just absolutely
hilarious I feel like those are like the
in those promos like it really like like
people kind of got to see that you have
like a really you you're funny man those
those promos were classic yeah yeah we
had we had fun when we were doing that
with couter and Jack Swagger but to be
honest I'm in the place where I need to
be where I where I feel more comfortable
I'm just having fun being the bad guy of
the movie that's the place where I want
to be that's the place where I feel more
comfortable and uh I'm and I know a lot
of people was disappointed when I uh
went back to the dog cuz you were you
were a good guy for it didn't seem like
it was long enough it was like 7 months
and a lot of people was disappointed
because they wanted to see me as a good
guy or baby face for for longer than
that but you know this the company and I
were talking and and we decide that this
is the best place for Alberto Rio I'm
I'm having a lot of fun I want to be
heel for the rest of my career so you
prefer to be a heel over a baby face
yeah yeah I mean big time if if I have
the opportunity I don't want to be a
baby face again but one more time we
work for the WWE and I'm going to be
wherever they want me to be awesome um
you and um like I was saying man you
have like some MMA experience and Brock
Lesner has been back for a while now you
guys ever link up and and and chitchat
about you know some of your MMA days
yeah yeah sometimes uh a little bit U
not a lot because we're always busy in
WWE especially the TV days we're doing
media we're doing around czy and then we
have the show and uh it's it's just
crazy but when we have the chance yes
yes we do talk um who are I with this
new show Total Divas we get to see that
like you know people are friends behind
the scenes like John Cena and and and um
Daniel Bryan have had this crazy you
know I wouldn't necessarily call it a
feud because they're both kind of good
guys and they you know they didn't hate
each other per se but you know they're
going at each other at SummerSlam and
then later on you watch Total Divas and
you know they're each taking their
girlfriends on a date together who are
some some your best friends in the
locker room well that
situation is it's not the same for
everybody at least for me I mean to be
honest I don't like the the 70% of the
guys in the company that's what I'm
saying who are who who close friends in
the locker room I don't hate anybody I
just I don't get along with anybody with
with with most of those guys I mean but
uh like guys like like Drew McIntyre is
my best friend in the business I mean
we're always riding together he goes to
my house in Florida all the time he was
the best man at my wedding oh wow yeah I
mean they need to get his ass out of 3MB
yeah right I and he's my best friend of
course Ricardo Rodriguez inara I mean a
lot of guys but you know it's it's it's
it's hard it's hard for me to make real
friends in this business because you
know I mean we we are we are always
together and some sometimes sometimes
you get tired of seeing these people
every single week every single day all
you want to do is just go home and enjoy
your family but uh but to mention some
names Drew and Ricardo will be my best
friends in the that's what's up uh who
are some people in the in the WWE I feel
like there's always like a few guys who
um who are really dope who might not get
the push that they deserve is there some
some wrestlers that you're fans of that
you think you know should kind of be uh
get a push from the company that maybe
don't have it right now well brother
there's a lot of guys and uh but
wrestling like life just like life
himself is not fair right oh defin it's
the same situation everywhere you go in
hospitals and and and for lawyers for
doctors for for for for
Architects sometimes they have a guys
with a lot of talent and they're not in
the spot that where they deserve is the
same situation in wrestling I have
there's a lot of guys here and and they
deserve to be Superstars or or main guys
unfortunately that's on my call we have
uh we have Vince manah running the
company and he's the one he's the boss
he's got for us he's the one who decides
where we go right right right right
indeed indeed and another thing uh this
2K14 this wrestling game uh the first
one the last one was crazy uh I hear
that the Ultimate Warrior supposed to
make an appearance in this uh in this
new one uh have you have you got the
chance to play it you play you play the
game when it comes out you ever play it
yourself uh no I I played the last one
but uh I haven't seen the new one yet
I'm not a big fan of video games like I
said I'm always working for WWE and when
I'm not I just go home and uh try to
take try to be a a a normal person and
take care of my kids
of course hey if you had to be in a in a
tag team uh a dream tag team partner
someone who's been relevant the last
five years who would who would your
dream tag team partner be if you ever
had to make a tag team run from the last
five five years yeah someone who's kind
of been you know I mean everyone might
go back back but you know let's say the
last five years someone who's been
relevant the last five years who's been
wrestling who who would be your your guy
you'd pick that you'd want to be in a
tag team with well um I always like to
go solo but to give you a name uh uh I
think it will be interesting to do
something with uh with Kane you know for
me it's it's a great performer one of
the Legends in WWE and if I if if I have
the opportunity to pick my my tag team
partner it will be Kane he did so I man
it's so crazy like just the the baby
face turn he did like all the
personality Kane showed when it when he
was rolling with Daniel Bryan it's a
good look one more thing to ask you
about uh Darren Young recently came out
he you know they just had a kickass
match on Raw they beat uh they they won
their match um what's your thoughts on
that man oh he's an amazing performer
and uh he's young he's talented he's in
the right business to to be somebody if
you love wrestling so he's going to be
just fine and and the company is going
to help him and uh all he has to do is
work hard train and and and stay focus
in his goals and he's going to be one of
the top
performers uh in the following years and
going into WrestleMania 30 next year if
you can um if can you even see yourself
that far down the line who would you
like to who is someone who's in WWE
right now who who you you would love
like a feud with going into WrestleMania
30 well I have had the opportunity to
work with everybody pretty much everyone
right Cena oron everybody and uh is
there someone who prefer in the ring to
work with or uh you know uh I always
have good matches I work I work hard 247
and then I'm not one of those guys who
go out and just because he's sick or
tired he doesn't give what the fans
deserve every time I go out I just I
give them everything more than 100%
because I respect this business I love
this business I was born in this
business and uh and at the end of the
day they pay our bills of course you
know so at this point it doesn't matter
it could it could be anybody uh
something I really want to do is to get
to the next WrestleMania as a world
heavyweight champ
I don't know if I'm going to be able to
keep that title for that long but if it
happens it will be fantastic that be a
long run that'd be a great run man so
hey thanks uh you've had a great run as
it is already even if it ended tomorrow
you know you've had a great run as World
Heavyweight Champion um much luck thank
you for your time man and you know my
son loves you you got anything you want
to ask him
Aiden no no he had something when you
were Drive in he's like I'm want to ask
him a qu he's all nervous now there we
go man Alberto Del Rio it's Power 98.3
Lake C show Power
98.3